In a democracy,
people can shape their future
to participation in decision making.
One way they can do this is by amending loss
if they're not happy with certain aspects.
Well, what exactly is a people's initiative
and explains
what is people's initiative?
A constitutional reform refers to a political
illegal process to amend or revise a current
constitution.
It is also known as charter change or charter.
And there are three ways to achieve this
constitutional reform.
First, the Constitutional Convention or conga.
This involves electing delegates
tasked solely with proposing
amendments to the constitution.
It is seen as more democratic
but can be time consuming and expensive.
Second, the Constituent Assembly or Conas.
We're in both houses of Congress
convened to propose amendments to the Constitution.
It is faster process
compared to constitutional convention,
but some fear it could be used for self serving
interest. Lastly,
the People's Initiative.
RBI allows citizens to directly propose amendments
through a petition process.
In Republic Act No. 6, 7,
3, 5 initiative means people's power to propose
constitutional amendments or legislation to an election.
Ten percent of nationwide voters
and 3% in each legislative district
must sign a petition.
Once the required signatures are gathered,
comic verifies them using the voter registry.
Previous attempts to amend the Constitution
Lexigo Nambian during Adar Ester fail.
In 2006, Lambino versus Kamala case,
the Supreme Court rejected an initiative
due to petitioners not meeting basic requirements
like showing the proposed amendment before
collecting signatures.
The debate over Chacha in
Congress has been in the headlines.
The house wants to use economic restrictions
while the Senate prioritizes checks and balances.
Pi also aims to seek the power of the house
in the Senate to vote as one
when approving changes to the Constitution
by a three fourths vote
which the senators
disagree with the house.
The Bay House Speaker
Martin Ramwaldis
assures Filipinos that proposed
amendments will focus on economic provisions
aiming to boost in job opportunities
and corporate access to social programs
through foreign investments.
Addressing the Lagan GDP gross
compared to neighboring counters.
Senator Ivy Marcos calls for a center view
while Senate President Juan Miguel Zubiri
proposes RB H
6 to amend economic
provisions by a Constituent Assembly
preserving by time
releasing additionally
the senators manifesto
wars of a potential no election scenario
if b I succeeds
as it could lead to contentious proposals
like protecting lands from foreign ownerships
or removing their limits in 2025 or 2028.
However, Albay 2nd District Representative
Joey Salceda
emphasized that the initiative for Chacha is better
to push long before the 2028 presidential elections
to assure the public
that there is no attempt to extend President
Marcus Sturr.
But what is really the motive of B I
proponents in these initiatives?
According to Professor Dante's Coronation,
a political analyst
and the USD
Department of Political Science chair,
it is hard to determine the true intention
the B I proponents.
It's really hard to,
you know, Determine
their true intention
because they might
expressly mention their intention
since there is no clear public support
uh for their uh
people's initiative.
I think it's
uh more of a,
it's determined by your
motivated by their private interest
or perhaps their own political agenda
from private interests
and people's initiative.
Wagnalang Siguro
allegations of signature buying for a people's
initiative have also been rampant since last year
as there were reports from different series.
Dava residents even testified
that they were made to sign the pre ship
in exchange for a Yudon that said
assess the issue of concern.
Is it urgent or is it the country's priority for now?
As a responsible Filipino citizen,
ask yourself first
the SPI means People's Initiative
for Public Interest or for private interest.